when you're testing if it functions even
what that means is that it it's
symmetric about the y-axis that you fold
over the y-axis so even functions have
y-axis symmetry and odd functions have
origin symmetry meaning if you rotate
them 180 degrees you turn them a half
turn about the origin like you're
pivoting at the origin and don't match
with themselves so even a nod is just
another way of saying y-axis and origin
symmetry but what you do the tests are a
little bit different so the test here
you're replacing X with negative x ok in
your function so whatever is in the
parentheses negative X you're going to
put that in place of X on the right if
you get back the original function
exactly like how the original function
is that tells you that it's even if you
replace X with negative x and you get
the same function back the same terms
but all the signs are the opposite ok if
they're positive they're negative
through negative they're positive
they're flipped that tells you that it's
odd and that it is a rotation about the
origin ok so I'll show you some examples
here let's take a look at this example f
of X equals 2x squared plus 4x to the
fourth if we put negative x in okay
we're gonna get two negative x the
quantity squared plus 4 times negative x
to the fourth power a negative 2 and
even power is a positive so we're just
going to get back to x squared a
negative 2 and even power we're going to
get a positive x to the fourth you can
see we're getting back the original
equation exactly how the original one
was so that tells you that this graph is
even ok it has even symmetry and it's a
reflection over the y axis but we just
call this even so this is the test for
even you're substituting in negative x
same thing over here we're going to put
negative x in place of X here on the
right and if we do that we get a
negative to an odd power which is going
to be negative so this works out to be
negative 5 X cubed it's exactly like the
original function but the sign here is
the opposite so that tells us that this
is
odd okay so we have even for this one
odd for this one okay now over here
we're gonna do the same thing we're
going to put negative X in place of X on
the right side of the equation so that
gives us two negative x squared notice I
put the negative X when I substitute in
parenthesis so I take it as a a whole
okay as a group a negative to an even
power is positive so that's giving us 2x
squared had negative times a negative is
a positive
and then this is just positive one so
let's look at what happened here this
one stayed the same see two x squared
they're both positive this one it's the
opposite this was a negative 3x this is
positive 3x and this is positive one
this one stayed the same this equation
is not the same as the original one so
it's not even okay the signs are not all
the opposite this would be negative two
x squared positive 3x negative one so
it's not odd so this falls into the
neither category it's neither even or
odd which means it's not symmetric about
the y-axis it's not a rotation about the
origin it's just neither so these are
the tests for even and odd similar in
some ways to the symmetry test we did
for x-axis y-axis and origin it
approaches a little bit different we're
using the function notation and we're
substituting negative x into the
equation so go ahead and review this
video if you need to otherwise I'll see
you in the next video